welcome back everybody we now know what
police in Washington took from the
apartment of Brian coburger the man
accused of killing four University four
college students at the nearby
University of Idaho a newly unsealed
warrant shows officers took among other
things one black glove the dust spin for
a vacuum cleaner a pillow with a quote
red brownish stain a Fire TV stick and
13 possible hair strands now it was
noted that these could be either human
or animal hairs police in Moscow Idaho
allege that coburger got into the rented
off-campus home and killed four of the
six people inside authorities laid out
multiple damning pieces of evidence
against co-burger and their probable
cause affidavit including linking him to
DNA found on a knife sheath left in one
of the bedrooms but what if he took
something back with him after reading
the Warren information many people are
wondering if that animal hair could
possibly belong to victim Kaylee
gonsalves dog named Murphy that dog was
at the home during the murders and if a
dog hair did make it back to coburger
Department can experts make any specific
determinations
you know a lot of the hair that shed you
know both from people and and from
animals
um
will have a little skin on it you know
right where it came out if there's some
of that they can they can connect it
directly to that dog the same as they
could with a person but if there is none
they can still compare the hair to the
dog's hair uh microscopically
and they can rule out you know most dogs
they can say well they can't identify it
as directly coming from that dog but
they can say that that's the exact same
kind of hair which rules out most dogs
um but isn't the same thing as having a
DNA test that says yes this came from
this dog
okay so Brian let's say that the dog
hair that was recovered from Goldberg is
from the same breed as the dog in the
victim's home does that mean that the
jury is definitely going to hear about
this evidence maybe maybe not now if
you're saying same breed I would say no
it would be like saying hey Jess
whoever's accused of killing a woman and
she's a redhead and Jesse has red hair
on his shirt I don't think that's enough
but if you can get it down to the
specific dog because I know most people
think oh it's hair and you can test it
but no you need the hair follicle or the
skin attached to the hair to test if you
could get it to the exact dog I think
that is the nail in the coffin it's
going to be a rough day for Brian
coburger and that probably one more
thing that convicts them but just to
breed judge might say it's not relevant
enough and keep it out of the trial
altogether did you do that on purpose I
think you did that on purpose yeah okay
it's fine uh Terry you actually took a
closer look at the search warrant in
general what else can you tell us about
it that we haven't talked about well the
original search warrant doesn't list all
of those individual items it just says
generally we have probable cause to look
for clothes and to look for any sort of
digital information and they went in
there and they found a ton of evidence
in his home they found the digital tower
that he worked with on his computer they
found a nitrix type glove a black glove
as you mentioned they found hair some
human some dog hair and they also found
a ton of information as far as receipts
are concerned and they're going to look
at those receipts to see if he purchased
anything else in connection with that
murder for instance the murder weapon
they did have in the search warrant a
sentence that said any sort of knife but
they didn't find that so they might
still find that knife if they look at
all of the evidence that they recovered
from that scene and we're all getting
more information you know as the weeks
progress as more information develops
you're seeing how they ultimately honed
in on him and why they honed him